เฮ
[Música]
Olá, minhas amigas, meus amigos.
Bem-vindos para mais uma live. Temos
poucas perguntas hoje, então vamos ter a
oportunidade de discutir alguns artigos
interessantes.
Pra primeira pergunta do dia, qual a
minha opinião sobre o teste Papa
Nicolau? Se pode ter controvérsias e
riscos? Eu achei uma pergunta bem
interessante. Eu também, para falar a
verdade, antes de ouvir essa pergunta,
eu não tava nem ciente desses
riscos e controvérsias. Eu fiz uma
pequena pesquisa e realmente pude
aprender sobre isso.
Bem, é um teste já utilizado há mais de
70 anos, então tem bastante tempo, porém
apesar dele ser de rotina nas mulheres,
ele tem sim limitações significativas
que tm que ser considerados de maneira
crítica.
Então, tem várias controvérsias e riscos
comentados aí na literatura
internacional
que merece uma análise cuidadosa.
Temos um primeiro detalhe do Papa
Nicolau que é a sensibilidade, que é
notavelmente baixa. Temos estudos aí de
metaanálises que demonstram uma
sensibilidade
variando entre 20 a 35%
e a especificidade em torno de 90 a 95%.
e alguns estudos reportando
sensibilidades tão baixas quanto 55
a 60% paraa detecção
de câncer de colo uterino, tá? Então
essa limitação fundamental significa que
o teste falha em detectar lesões
pré-cancerosas
e uma proporção substancial de casos.
Então, quais são as principais
controvérsias identificadas
sobre diagnóstico? é um e sobre
tratamento é outro. Então tem evidências
que mostram que muitas lesões cervicais,
ou seja, do colo uterino
pré-cancerígenas
vão regredir espontaneamente. Então pode
ser que você fazer esse diagnóstico leve
a tratamentos necessários.
Em mulheres jovens entre 20 a 24 anos,
91% das displazias cervicais
regridem espontaneamente em 36 meses.
Então, um órgão americano chamado SPSTF
reconhece que a identificação e o
tratamento dessas lesões que regrediriam
naturalmente constituem sobre
diagnóstico, levando a procedimentos
necessários. Então, taxas de falso
positivo são particularmente elevadas em
mulheres abaixo de 30 anos devido a
infecções transitórias pelo vírus do
HPV. Então, essa filosofia diz que
mulheres abaixo de 30 talvez não
devessem fazer esse rastreamento aí para
pra HPV.
Então, quais são os riscos associados ao
rastreamento, né? né? Então vamos falar
prós e contras aqui. Os prós haveria uma
redução histórica documentada de 50 a
80% na mortalidade por câncer de
coluterino cervical em populações com
programas bem estruturados. teria uma
especificidade relativamente alta de 75
a 97% dependendo do estudo. É um exame
muito conhecido com décadas de
experiência,
o custo relativamente baixo
e o valor preditivo positivo razoável
quando seria aplicado em populações de
alto risco. Quais seriam os contras do
teste Papai Nicolau? Uma sensibilidade
baixa entre 20 a 60%.
como eu falei, né, resultando em altas
taxas de falso negativo, uma taxa de
falso positivo de 40%, que é reportado
em alguns estudos e levaria a vários
procedimentos diagnósticos subsequentes
que poderiam causar morbidade, né, como
é o caso da coposcopia e da biópsia, que
poderiam causar sangramento, dor e
infecção.
e também levando a tratamentos invasivos
como a conização, que é a retirada da
capinha assim do colo uterino, e uma
excisão eletrocirúrgica, né? Isso
poderia est associado a resultados ruins
caso essa mulher engravide. o aumento
significativo de partos prematuros e
complicações perinatais
após procedimentos de retirada, né,
dessa capinha do colo uterino. Poderia
gerar ansiedade e sofrimento psicológico
associado a resultados anormais e uma
variabilidade entre observadores
significativa na interpretação do exame.
Então, a tendência atual é mais
conservadora,
pelo menos entre os mais conservadores,
questiona a aplicação indiscriminada do
rastreamento, especialmente populações
jovens, como eu comentei, né, em
mulheres abaixo de 30 anos. E o American
Cancer Society revisou as diretrizes em
2020 e não tá recomendando mais o
rastreamento antes dos 25, reconhecendo
que os danos superam os benefícios nessa
faixa etária.
A evidência sugere que o paradigma de
quanto mais rastreamento melhor é falha.
Intervalos de rastreamento mais longos
de 3 a 5 anos tem uma eficácia similar
com redução substancial de danos e o
valor preditivo positivo de rastreamento
anual após o teste negativo é
praticamente zero nos primeiros 2 anos.
Então, valeria a pena fazer a partir dos
25, 30 anos e dar um intervalo de 3 a 5
anos entre cada avaliação.
Então, a perspectiva conservadora
deveria considerar que o teste Papa
Nicolau, ele nunca foi avaliado em
ensaios clínicos randomizados
controlados. Ele é baseado inteiramente
em dados observacionais
e a implementação massiva de
rastreamento em mulheres jovens poderia
representar uma intervenção médica
excessiva em população predominantemente
saudável, violando o princípio médico
fundamental de não causar dono, né, o
primo não série.
Então, a literatura também demonstra que
países em desenvolvimento gastam
recursos substanciais em programa de
rastreamento com Papai Nicolau, quando
outras intervenções de saúde pública
poderiam ser mais impactantes.
E pesquisadores argumentam que o atraso
na implementação de métodos
alternativos, devido à insistência do
Papai Nicolau, contribuiu para centenas
de milhares de mortes evitáveis em
países como a Índia, né, que tem uma
população muito grande. Isso eu não
sabia. Então, em suma, o teste de Papai
Nicolau tem limitações técnicas
significativas, riscos substanciais de
sobretratamento, seja tratamento
exagerado e consequências reprodutivas
adversas que frequentemente são
minimizadas no discurso médico
convencional. Então, uma abordagem mais
conservadora e baseada em evidências.
Então, começando o exame mais tarde na
vida da mulher e dando um intervalo mais
longo entre um exame e outro, parece a
abordagem mais sensata.
OK.
A próxima pergunta, tem alguém
acompanhando ao vivo, pessoal? Porque eu
não tô tendo nenhum tipo de comentário
aqui e eu não sei se o áudio tá bom, tá?
Então gostaria que vocês se
manifestassem se vocês estão, se alguém
está acompanhando ao vivo.
Ã,
deixa eu mandar mensagem aqui no grupo.
Bem, a segunda pergunta, doutor, a
reposição de vitamina D injetável,
600.000 unidades com uma única dose, tem
risco maior do que fazer seis aplicações
de 50.000?
Mas geralmente 50.000 eu não conheço
50.000 injetav, geralmente é oral
50.000.
Então eu já fiz várias vezes aplicação
de 600.000 unidades em mim mesmo, né? Eu
nunca tive nenhum tipo de problema com
isso. Eu acho muito conveniente, tá? Mas
a gente tem que reconhecer que a
administração dentro do músculo, né,
intramuscular, de doses maiores
tem características farmacocinéticas
diferentes quando comparado a você
fracionar, por exemplo, 50.000 unidades
por semana. Então, na verdade, uma
resposta rápida a essa pergunta é: sim,
poderia fazer 50.000 unidades oral por
semana.
Eh, seria até mais fisiológico do que
tomar 600.000 de uma vez. Eu,
particularmente, eu nunca tive problema
aplicando intramuscular.
Quando você aplica 600.000 unidades
intramusculares, o pico no sangue vai
dar os 4 meses, porque esse conteúdo de
vitamina D fica no tecido gorduroso, né,
da aplicação intramuscular no glúteo,
ela não vai pro sangue e vai sendo
administrada aos poucos no organismo.
Então o pico vai ser aos 4 meses da
aplicação e vai ter um declínio gradual
com níveis terapêuticos aos 12 meses.
Então tem essa vantagem de durar
bastante tempo. A injeção vai ter uma
liberação prolongada e sustentada,
como eu falei, do depósito
intramuscular,
porém existe um risco de hipercalcemia
transitória, ou seja, aumento do cálcio
no sangue transitório nos primeiros 3 a
4 meses.
Enquanto se você fizer dose mais
fracionada, 50.000 por semana, por
exemplo, vai dar uma elevação mais
gradual e controlada.
Isso em níveis séricos, vai dar uma
menor variabilidade interpessoal na
resposta, vai ter picos séricos menos
pronunciados e menor incidência de
hipercalciúria transitória. Então,
realmente é mais vantajoso fazer 50.000
unidades semanais.
Então, em termos de hipercalcemia, que é
o excesso de cálcio no sangue, com a
dose única de 600.000 de unidades.
Existe uma incidência relatada na
literatura de aproximadamente 8 a 12% de
aumento desse cálcio no sangue, que é
transitório e assintomático geralmente e
que resolve sozinho.
seria um risco maior desse cálcio
aumentado no sangue em pacientes com
mutações do CIP 24 A1, né, que é uma
mutação genética aí do
metabolismo e um risco aumentado de
administração
concomitante com cálcio suplementar, né?
Então
essa seria a situação.
Enquanto você faz doses fracionadas, o
risco de hipalcemia é muito baixo, é
quatro casos para cada 1000 indivíduos.
E existe também a possibilidade de você
fazer um ajuste ou suspensão
eh dessa vitamina D se houver algum
problema no meio do caminho.
Mas falando em termos práticos, na
prática a gente vê muita segurança de
fazer uma dose única de 600.000
unidades. Como eu falei, essa a minha
prática para mim mesmo que eu mais
gosto, tá? porque eu nunca tive problema
com isso.
Porém, se você quer ficar do lado mais
seguro possível, 50.000 semanais é
melhor, sim. Tá.
E é muito importante avaliar esse
paciente antes para ver se ele não tem
um hiperparatiroidismo
eh que não foi diagnosticado antes, se
não tem uma função renal já alterada que
com megados de vitamina D poderia dar
problema. Você não tá usando diurésicos
tiasídicos, que poderia aumentar o risco
aí de complicações com cálcio, se não é
um portador de uma doença granulomatosa,
como tuberculose ou sarcolidose, que
poderia aumentar o risco também de
acúmulo de cálcio,
se não tem mutação genéticas no
metabolismo da vitamina D
e pessoas também com idade mais avançada
que tenha maior risco de ter função
renal limítrofe. Sì.
Próxima pergunta. Eu vi um vídeo onde o
cara diz para não usar bicarbonato ou
vinagre para lavar frutas e vegetais,
porque causaria dano na camada externa,
deve ser do vegetal, né? E fazer com que
os pesticidas entrem dentro da fruta e
do vegetal,
certo? Recomenda-se usar detergente sem
fragância.
Segundo ele, pesticidas não são solúveis
em água e usando detergente sem
fragância eliminaria melhor. Qual que é
a minha opinião? Pois uso o bicarbonato
primeiro para remover os pesticidas
e depois de enxaguar eu deixo no vinagre
para sanitizar.
Bem, eu dei uma revisada na literatura.
Esse vídeo que você comenta pode ter
informações
parcialmente incorretas, né? Tome
cuidado com as fontes que vocês estão
checando.
Então, sobre a alegação de que o
bicarbonato e vinagre danificam a camada
externa dos vegetais, isso permitiria a
penetração de pesticida. Isso, pelo que
eu pesquisei, não é correto, tá? Tá? A
evidência científica demonstra
e praticamente o oposto disso. Daí teve
um estudo que foi publicado no Journal
of Agricultural and Food Chemistry pela
Universidade de Massachusetts em 2017,
que demonstrou que o bicarbonato de
sódio foi o método mais eficaz para
remover pesticidas superficiais
quando comparado com água corrente ou
solução de cloro. Então, a solução de
bicarbonato a 10 mg por ml removeu
completamente os pesticidas tiabendazol
e fosmete em 12 a 15 minutos de imersão.
Então, o mecanismo de ação do
bicarbonato é interessante. O pH
alcalino do bicarbonato degrada vários
pesticidas
porque a maioria deles não é estável em
pH alcalino.
Então isso facilitaria a remoção física
durante a lavagem subsequente.
E o estudo demonstrou uma remoção de até
96%, bastante coisa, hein, dos
pesticidas de superfície, sendo
significativamente superior à água pura
que remove apenas cerca de 50%.
sobre o uso de detergente sem fragância,
né? Seria esse o ponto mais problemático
da recomendação que você viu no vídeo.
Quais seriam os aspectos negativos
disso? Os detergentes modernos não são
sabões verdadeiros, são compostos
sintéticos desenhados para remover
gordura e óleo. E esses compostos
poderiam efetivamente remover a camada
cerosa protetora das frutas e vegetais.
e isso teria consequências indesejadas.
Então, a remoção da cutícula cerosa
tornaria o produto mais vulnerável a
contaminação microbiana, viral e
fungica, além de acelerar a perda da
água e a deteroração. Então, fudas
vegetais tem poros que podem absorver os
detergentes, tornando difícil remover
completamente, mesmo com enxague
abundante. Então, os órgãos FDA e USDA
americanos, explicitamente não
recomendam o uso de detergentes ou
sabões para lavar produtos alimentícios,
pois esses não foram aprovados ou
rotulados para isso. E você não pode
consumir, então, esse detergente, já que
você não consegue remover depois ele do
vegetal.
Então, estudos mostram que resíduos de
detergente podem permanecer no alimento
mesmo após o enxague e representa um
risco adicional à saúde. Então, eh,
aspectos positivos limitados do
detergente poderia ser eficaz na remoção
de pesticidas não polares devido à
capacidade de dissolver compósos
oleosos, tá? teria um estudo coreano com
vegetais foliosos e o detergente
comercial a 0,5%
reduziu resíduos em 71 a 87.9%,
mas foi em condições controladas com
produtos específicos. Então no geral não
utilize detergente para isso.
Já o bicarbonato de sódio que você tá
utilizando,
ele tem essa grande vantagem, como eu
falei, ele remove de 80 a 96% dos
pesticidas superficiais.
Degrada quimicamente vários pesticidas,
é seguro para consumo, não deixa resíduo
prejudicial, mantém a integridade da
cutícula protetora dos vegetais e é o
método validado cientificamente.
Tem um contra a respeito disso, uma
desvantagem que ele requer de 12 a 15
minutos paraa máxima eficácia.
Ele não remove pesticidas,
pesticidas sistêmicos que penetraram no
interior do vegetal e pode alterar
levemente o sabor se não for bem
enxaguado. O vinagre, que é a segunda
etapa aí que você tá utilizando,
tem vários próst, tem propriedades
antimicrobianas naturais, remove alguns
pesticidas, 51 a 67% em alguns estudos.
é seguro para consumo, ajuda na
sanitização contra patógenos, teria o
contra de ser menos eficaz com o
bicarbonato para pesticidas, poderia
deixar também o sabor residual e o ácido
acético poderia amolecer alguns vegetais
delicados.
A água corrente sozinha só remove de 40
a 50% dos pesticidas superficiais,
porém pode remover sujeira e detritos.
Então ele é menos eficaz do que você
utilizar o vinagre ou utilizar o
bicarbonato.
O detergente sem fragância teria essa
vantagem de reduzir pescidas oleosos que
não são solúveis em água.
Porém vai remover a camada protetora
natural da planta.
pode ser removido pelos, aliás, pode ser
absorvido pelos poros do alimento,
não é aprovada pro uso alimentar, como
eu comentei, você vai acabar ingerindo o
resíduo químico desse detergente e
poderia aumentar a vulnerabilidade a
alguns patógenos. Então, a recomendação
que eu faria a você,
o que você tá utilizando atualmente é
uma abordagem superior ao que foi
sugerido no vídeo. Essa combinação
bicarbonato com vinagre tem benefícios
interessantes, benefícios sinégérgicos,
né? Então, o bicarbonato degrada e
remove pesticidas, enquanto o vinagre
providencia uma sanitização adicional.
Então, essa sequência é cientificamente
sólida.
E para otimizar essa sequência, eu
sugiro você colocar primeiro imersão em
solução de bicarbonato, uma colher de
chá para duas colheres, para duas
xícaras de água, ou seja, uma colher de
chá para duas xícaras de água por 12 a
15 minutos, depois enxaguar
completamente em água corrente, depois
fazer uma imersão rápida em solução de
vinagre, um para três com água por 2 a 3
minutos e fazer um enxague final.
E é importante lembrar que isso vai
remover os pesticidas externos, né? Os
sistêmicos que penetraram no interior do
alimento, não podem ser completamente
removidos por nenhum método de lavagem.
E a única forma de removê-los
completamente seria descascar o
alimento, o que vai reduzir o valor
nutricional.
E essa alegação de que pesticidas não
são solúveis em água não é correta. É
uma generalização incorreta. Muitos
pesticidas modernos são parcialmente ou
totalmente solúveis em água e mesmos não
solúveis podem ser removidos
mecanicamente pela ação da lavagem
combinada com a degradação química
proporcionada pelo bicarbonato. Então,
concluindo, continue com o seu protocolo
atual. é melhor do que você viu no
vídeo, é cientificamente superior, mais
seguro e não introduz riscos adicionais
como uso de detergentes não aprovados
para alimentos, tá? Então não siga a
recomendação do vídeo.
Próxima pergunta. O uso do óleo de coco
como protetor solar é bom?
Eu
quando fiz o curso do Dr. Lai Ribeiro,
né, ele era recomendado o uso do óleo de
coco como protetor solar. Mas fazendo
uma revisão da literatura científica
mais recente,
e também eu concluí que isso, na minha
opinião, condiz, né?
O uso do óleo de coco como protetor
solar não é recomendado como alternativa
eficaz aos fitos solares,
porque estudos laboratoriais demonstram
que o óleo de coco virgem apresenta um
fator de proteção solar FPS muito baixo,
né? Os autores Caur e Saraf, num estudo
publicado no PMC em 2010 determinaram
através de métodos espectrofotométricos
em vitro que o óleo de coco possui um
FPS muito baixo de 7,1.
estudos mais recentes, incluindo de
Martinia Cová e colaboradores de 2021,
que foi publicado Photochemical and
Photobiological Science, encontraram
valores ainda menores de FPS de apenas
2,6 a 2,8. Então, contextualizando,
é fundamental compreender que um FPS de
7 bloqueia apenas cerca de 86%
dos RIS UVB,
deixando 14% da radiação atingir a pele.
E em comparação, um protetor solar com
FPS 30, considerado o mínimo recomendado
pela maioria das organizações
dematológicas, bloqueia 97%
dos raios UVB. A Meoclinic
especifica que o óleo de coco bloqueia
apenas 20% da radiação travioleta total
comparado aos 97%
pelos protões solares com FPS a partir
de 30.
E também outra coisa é que o ódio coco
tem uma proteção insignificante
contra a radiação UVA, que é responsável
pelo fotoenvelhecimento
e danos mais profundos na pele. Então,
teve um estudo de 2016 que foi publicado
no International Journal of Cosmetic
Science que demonstrou que o óleo de
coco e outros óleos naturais testados
tiveram uma absorção virtualmente nula
na faixa de comprimento de onda de 320 a
400 nanôm. Boa noite, Alice Vogel.
Obrigado. Tá comparecendo ao vivo.
Então, a variabilidade dos valores de
FPS que foi relatado entre vários
estudos diferentes também levanta
questões sobre a confiabilidade e a
reprodução da proteção oferecida. Então,
fatores como origem do óleo, método de
extração, condições de armazenamento,
composição específica de ácidos grassos,
poderiam influenciar qualquer capacidade
fotoprotetora residual. Boa noite,
Josué.
Do ponto de vista farmacocinético, o
óleo de coco tem limitações práticas,
né? A textura oleosa dificulta a
formação de um fio uniforme e duradouro
sobre a pele. Em temperaturas elevadas,
o óleo faz ficar mais liquefeito e pode
escorrer e vai comprometer ah qualquer
proteção marginal. Além disso, não há
estudos demonstrando fotoabilidade
adequada do óleo de coco sob.
Então é importante entender o seguinte,
não é porque eu tô dizendo que o óleo de
coco não é um bom filtro solar, não quer
dizer que ele não tem boas propriedades
benéficas para cuidados com a pele, tá?
Então uma coisa não anula a outra, tá?
Então, tem um estudo aí de VARMA e
colaboradores em 2019 que foi publicado
no Journal of Traditional and
Complementary Medicine, em que foi
demonstrado que o óleo de coco virgem
tem propriedades antiinflamatórias
importantes,
incluindo inibição de citocinas
inflamatórias.
E esse estudo também mostrou, né, uma
regulação de marcadores importantes da
barreira cutânea.
Então, essas propriedades tornariam o
óleo de coco excelente para cuidados pós
o sol, não durante o sol, e como
emoliente em formulações cosméticas, mas
não como protetor solar, né, por si só.
Então, lembrando que alguns estudos são
frequentemente citados de maneira
incorreta. Teve um estudo que foi
publicado em 2000, que poderia sugerir
um fator de proteção solar para o óleo
de semente framboesa entre 28 e 50.
Só que esse estudo foi desacreditado
por estudos posteriores.
Então essa desinformação também pode
estender a hora de coco com alguns blogs
e sites exagerando a capacidade
protetora.
Então, praticamente falando, o de coco,
ele poderia ser considerado apenas como
adjuvante, ou seja, como um auxílio em
formulações de proteção solar
adequadamente formuladas e serviria como
veículo emoliente poder melhorar a
espalhabilidade e aderência de
ingredientes ativos. É o caso do óxido
de zinco, tá?
Odiat em 2017 ele demonstrou que a
combinação do óleo de coco com filtros
ultravioleta convencionais
poderia ser favorável, mas o óleo por si
não ofereceu proteção adequada.
Bem, eu quando
recomendo o uso de filtros solares, eu
recomendo os filtros solares da família
Tinossorbe,
porque é uma evolução significativa na
tecnologia da falta proteção, oferece
uma vantagem substancial sobre os
filtros convencionais.
Então, a família Tinossorbe, ela é
composta por três compostos
desenvolvidos pela BASF. Você
tem oossob S, tinossob mem e o tinossob
A2B.
E esses filtros têm características
superiores que distinguem dos filtros
tradicionais, tá? Então, quando for
trabalhar com filtro solar, trabalhe com
os filtros solares da família do
Tinossorb.
Houve estudos comparativos publicados no
Journal of the American Academy of the
Hematology, mostrando que oabs
é o filtro ultravioleta mais eficaz
disponível quando medido por FPS,
baseado na concentração máxima permitida
pela legislação europeia.
E a segurança desses filtros sinossob
tem sido extensivamente
investigada.
Não tem ação estrogênica, não tem ação
antiestrogênica ou antiandrogênica,
né? Ao contrário de alguns filtros
convencionais, como é o caso da
oxidenzona, que podem ter ação de
disuptor endócrino.
E também tem uma questão de
versatilidade formulativa dos filtros,
que permite o uso de diversos sistemas
cosméticos.
Tá? Então essa dica que eu dou para
você,
porque os filtros que nós sobem hoje em
dia são o estado da arte em tecnologia
de proteção solar.
Bem, tem perguntas ao vivo aqui. Ozônio
poderia retirar esses pecidas
sistêmicos?
Não, Thago. Poderia ajudar a remover
também os pesticidas externos, os que
foram absorvidos pela planta.
Infelizmente nenhum método vai ser
eficaz, viu?
Próximo. Ah, as perguntas já foram.
Deixa eu ver se tem alguma pergunta ao
vivo que eu não Ah, tem mais sim. Tem o
pessoal colocou mais perguntas aqui.
Dr. Alan, já ouviu falar da psicologia
de Leopoldo Zond inconsciente familiar?
É muito interessante. Acho que usando
essa psicologia aliada a suplementos
pode talvez curar muitas doenças
familiares.
Vou dar uma olhada, tá? Não conheço
isso.
Não conheço, sinceramente. Eu não
conheço. Eu não tive tempo de ver com
mais antecedência porque você mandou a
pergunta bem em cima.
Vou
deixar essa pergunta aqui pra próxima
live.
Me dê só um instante aqui.
Aí nós conversamos sobre isso na
próxima.
Mulher de 54 anos, diabética, fez
cirurgia no oco do braço. Que que é o do
braço? Próximo ao palco. Qual dica você
dá de suplementos e cuidados?
Deve ser no osso do braço, né?
Agora, próximo ao palco. O que que é
palco? Não quis, não entendi isso aqui.
Enfim. Tá, vamos lá.
cirurgia no osso do braço.
Aí seria mais suplementos para auxiliar
na cicatrização, né,
e também na
recuperação do osso. E tá um pouco
esquisita essa pergunta aqui, mas vamos
lá. Eu entraria com MSM, né, o metil
sufonil metano, que é um excelente
agente antiinflamatório aí para osso.
Poderia entrar também com DMSO, seria
uma ótima. Entraria com colágenolizado
tipo dois para ajudar também. Entraria
com ácido hialurônico,
entraria com vitamina D, K2.
Corcumina também ajudaria muito,
entraria com, se tivesse com muita dor
também entraria com pea, né, ou palmito
etanolamina.
Teria vários suplementos aí que a gente
poderia utilizar.
Próxima pergunta. Qual a sua visão da
nova vacina anticâncer da Rússia? também
preciso pesquisar sobre isso. Não
tenho
muitos conhecimento sobre isso.
Podemos falar sobre isso na próxima live
aqui.
T deixar anotado aqui.
Vi o vídeo onde o cara disse para não
usar bicarbonato vinagre para lavar
frutas e vegetais. Porque causa Não,
esse aqui eu já respondi,
acho que ficou fora da ordem.
O uso do co comprutolar também já
respondi.
Dra. Alan, a dieta cetogênica ajuda na
cicatrização e recuperação da mulher que
fez cirurgia? Sim,
pode ajudar porque é uma dieta altamente
anti-inflamatória.
Porém, vai depender também
se a pessoa que fez a cirurgia, pessoa
ficar muito tempo internada, perdeu
peso, né, perdeu muita massa muscular,
às vezes é importante o comer
carboidratos para poder a pessoa
recuperar o peso, tá? Então vai depender
muito da situação específica, tá?
Bem, vamos lá.
Eu queria falar com vocês sobre um
artigo chamado Sete Verdade sobre
síntese proteica muscular. E o que que a
ciência revela? Vocês sabem que a
síntese proteína muscular
poderia ser similar
dietas veganas e onívoras, porque tem
muita gente que acha que o vegano tem
deficiência proteica, né? E pode ter
sim, pode ter sim se ele não tiver
alguns cuidados, mas não é todo mundo
que é
vegano que vai ter necessariamente
deficiência proteica.
Então, o processo pro ganho de massa
muscular tem sido objeto de debates
acalorados da comunidade fitness,
mas um novo estudo rigoroso de 9 dias de
duração trouxe revelações
surpreendentes.
A questão central não é apenas qual
proteína você consome, mas como o seu
corpo a utiliza para construir e manter
a massa muscular. Então, durante anos,
se acreditou que proteínas animais
seriam muito superiores pro anabolismo,
né, pro crescimento muscular, mas a
ciência atual não está dando suporte
mais a esse pensamento, a essa crença.
Então
vamos analisar
por que a fonte proteica pode não ser
tão determinante quanto pensávamos, como
a distribuição das refeições afeta os
ganhos musculares e qual é a quantidade
ideal de proteína para otimizar a sí
muscular, além de estratégias práticas
baseadas em evidências científicas
atualizadas.
Então, a síntese proteica muscular
representa o processo metabólico pelo
qual o corpo constrói novas proteínas
musculares. Esse mecanismo complexo
envolve a tradução do RNA mensageiro em
cadeias de aminoácidos que transformam
as proteínas contráteis no músculo,
formam essas proteínas contráteis do
músculo. Então, no nível celular, esse
processo ocorre nos ribossomos e é
regulado principalmente pela via emitor,
tá?
Então essa famosa via emitor, que é a
via responsável pela hipertrofia
muscular. Quando você consome proteínas
e pratica exercício de resistência, ou
seja, exercício de força, você ativa
essa via de sinalização,
estimulando a construção de novo tecido
muscular. Então, para que haja essa
hipertrofia muscular efetiva, a taxa da
síntese proteica muscular tem que ser
superior a taxa de degradação. Então,
esse balanço positivo, ele é mantido
consistentemente ao longo do tempo e
resulta em ganho de massa muscular.
Então, teve um estudo randomizado
controlado de 9 dias que comparou a
síntese proteica muscular entre 40
adultos jovens com idade média de 25
anos, índice massa corporal médio de 24,
que estavam consumindo dietas veganas ou
onívoras, ou seja, com carnes e
vegetais. Os participantes receberam
todas as refeições fornecidas pelos
pelos pesquisadores. Então, foi bem
rigoroso. Então, foi um estudo muito
mais válido que esses estudos que a
gente vê por aí que te questionário de
alimentação.
Então, as dietas foram calculadas para
manter o peso corporal, contendo 1,1 a
1,2 g de proteína por kg de peso
corporal diariamente.
na dieta onora que ia de tudo, 70% da
proteína vinha de carne bovina, frango,
laticínios e porco. E as fontes
específicas de proteína vegana não foram
detalhadas no estudo.
Então, o design incluiu dois padrões de
distribuição proteica, balanceado com
cinco refeições com 20% de proteína
cada, e desbalanceado com três refeições
com 10, 30 e 60% de proteína diária.
Então, durante o período, os
participantes completaram três sessões
supervisionadas
de exercício resistido. E qual foi o
resultado? As taxas de síntese proteica
muscular foram similares entre todos os
grupos, independentemente da fonte
proteica, será vegetal animal ou da
distribuição dessa proteína ao longo do
tempo. Então isso prova que proteínas
vegetais podem ser sim tão anólicas
quanto as animais,
porque nós tradicionalmente pensamos que
proteínas vegetais são consideradas
inferiores devido ao menor conteúdo de
aminoácidos essenciais e da
digestibilidade menor. Contudo,
evidências recentes, como desse estudo
que eu tô comentando, estão desafiando
essa visão. Quando a dose total de
proteína atinge pelo menos 30 g por
refeição,
as diferenças da citica muscular entre
fonte vegetal e animal,
a partir desse limiar de 30 g, essa
diferença desaparece.
Isso ocorre porque a quantidade absoluta
de aminoácidos essenciais disponíveis e
se torna suficiente para maximizar a
resposta anabólica.
Então, estudos anteriores que mostraram
superioridade
das proteínas animais utilizavam doses
menores que 30 g e proteínas de fonte
única.
Esse que foi a diferença,
dose menor de 30 g e fonte única de
proteínas. Então, na prática, nós
consumimos múltiplas fontes proteicas,
arroz, feijão, por exemplo, criando um
perfil aminoacídico mais completo.
Então, a combinação estratégica de
diferentes proteínas vegetais pode
fornecer todos os aminoácidos essenciais
necessários para otimizar a síntese
proteica muscular, especialmente quando
o consumo total diário é adequado.
E esse estudo também sugeriu que a
distribuição proteica ao longo do dia
pode não importar. Existia um conceito
tradicional que sugeria consumir
proteína a cada 3 a 4 horas para
maximizar
a cites proteica muscular. E essa
recomendação era baseada em estudos de
curta duração que mediram a resposta
anabólica por poucas horas após o
consumo. Entretanto, pesquisas mais
longas revelam que doses maiores de
proteínas, como 100 g mantém a cítes
elevada por períodos mais longos, mais
estendidos.
Entre 4 a 12 horas pós consumo, a taxa
de síntese foi 40% maior com doses
elevadas comparado a doses moderadas.
Então, estudos com jejum intermitente
corroboraram esses achados.
participantes que foram consumindo toda
a proteína diária em janela de 8 horas
ainda apresentaram ganhos musculares
similares aos que distribuíram as
refeições ao longo do dia. Então isso
sugere que o total diário de proteína é
bem mais importante do que o timing.
Isso oferece flexibilidade para
diferentes estilos de vida e
preferências alimentares.
Particularmente não como de três a de
três em três, quatro em 4 horas. Para
mim isso é muito importante, que não é
tão importante esse timing.
Então a quantidade total de proteínas é
o fator determinante.
A síntese proteica muscular responde
primariamente à quantidade total de
proteína consumida diariamente nas 24
horas e não a fonte ou distribuição
temporal. Então esse princípio
fundamental simplifica muito as
recomendações nutricionais, graças a
Deus. Então, para indivíduos ativos,
o consumo de 1,6 a 2,2 g de proteína por
kilograma de peso corporal otimiza os
ganhos musculares.
Atletas e idosos podem beneficiar-se de
quantidades no limite superior dessa
faixa. E a qualidade proteica ainda
importa, mas pode ser compensada
aumentando a quantidade total quando se
consome predominantemente fontes
vegetais.
Então, o vegano precisaria consumir 10 a
20% mais proteína total para compensar,
né, a questão do vegetal ter menos
aminoácidos essenciais e garantir então
a quantidade suficiente desses
aminoácidos. Então o foco tem que tá em
atingir consistentemente a meta diária
de proteína, independentemente de como
você escolhe distribuir essa proteína ou
quais as fontes que você vai obter, tá?
E aí existe uma coisa que eu já comentei
em lives anteriores, que é uma coisa
nova, que é a micoproteína, que é a
proteína que vem de fontes aí, né, de
fungos.
Ela emerge como alternativas
promissoras. Ela apresenta um perfil de
aminoácido similar ao leite
e tem uma digestibilidade superior a
muitas proteínas vegetais convencionais.
Então, estudos mostram que 57% da
proteína em dietas veganas que são
bem-sucedidas para a síntese muscular
venho de fungos, micoproteína.
Então, essa fonte única combina a
sustentabilidade ambiental. com eficácia
anabórica comprovada,
porém não está amplamente disponível
comercialmente
e poderia representar o futuro das
proteínas alternativas. E a produção
desse tipo de proteína requer menos
recursos que proteínas animais e oferece
uma qualidade nutricional superior às
proteínas vegetais tradicionais.
Então, fique com isso na cabeça. A
micoproteína pode ser uma excelente
alternativa,
complementando
com estratégias de combinações
estratégicas com leguminosas, grãos e
oleagenosas para os veganos.
Sempre lembrando que a síntese proteica
muscular depende da sinergia entre
nutrição adequada e estímulo mecânico.
Tem que fazer exercício físico de força,
senão não vai ter ganho muscular,
porque esse exercício vai ativar as vias
de sinalização celular que potencializam
a utilização dos aminoácidos poníveis.
A janela anabólica pós treino, ela
permanece elevada por 24 a 48 horas. Não
é apenas nas primeiras horas, como era
pensado inicialmente.
Isso reforça que o consumo proteico
total de áo importa muito mais do que o
time imediato pós exercício.
Então é muito importante combinar o
treino resistido de força, progressivo
com aumento de carga e consumo proteico
adequado, focando na sobrecarga
progressiva e recuperação apropriada
entre as sessões.
Obviamente adultos jovens têm maior
flexibilidade metabólica
e vão se adaptar mais eficientemente a
diferentes fontes e padrões de consumo
proteico.
Esse estudo que eu comentei focou nessa
população jovem. Idos podem requerer
estratégias mais específicas devido à
resistência anabólica relacionado à
idade. Pode necessitar de doses maiores
de proteína por refeição na faixa de 40
g. E podem exigir também a adição de
leucina extra para estimular
adequadamente a citica.
Cada atleta de elite vai se beneficiar
de abordagens individualizadas
baseados em demandas específicas do
esporte que ele pratica, né? Enquanto o
total diário de proteína é crucial, o
timing para os exportistas
pode influenciar a recuperação muscular
e adaptações específicas ao treinamento.
O vegano tem que ter muito cuidado com a
sua dieta. Tem que ter muito mais
atenção do que o onívoro. Tem que focar
em variedade de fontes, quantidade. Eu
vejo muito vegano que tem dieta muito
eh monótona e aí tem problema porque não
não acrescenta eh por exemplo algas, não
acrescenta cogumelos, né, que é um tipo
de fungo a sua alimentação. Então, é
importante combinar múltiplas fontes
proteicas para poder garantir o perfil
de aminoácidos adequado.
Então, como aplicar esse conhecimento na
prática? Então, para maximizar a síntese
proteica muscular, calcule a sua
necessidade diária, multiplicando o peso
em kilogram por 1,6 a 2,2. Um indivíduo
de 70 kg, então, necessitaria de 112 a
154 g de proteína todos os dias.
Distribua essa quantidade conforme a
preferência pessoal e rotina. poderia
consumir três refeições grandes
ou cinco a seis refeições menores.
E essa flexibilidade é totalmente
possível, tá?
Então, em relação aos veganos, tem que
fazer uma combinação variada de fontes
proteicas,
por exemplo, arroz com feijão, quinoa
com lentilhas, proteína de ervilha com
proteína de arroz.
sempre evitando os alimentos
processados.
Priorize os que são minimamente
processados e utilize suplementos
estrategicamente quando necessário para
atingir as metas. Se você não conseguir
atingir as metas com alimentação. Então
você pode usar o protein caseína, eu não
recomendo, mas é uma fonte proteica,
proteínas vegetais em pó ou aminoácidos
isolados.
Lembrando que pessoas que têm doença
renal crônica tem que fazer uso moderado
de proteína porque pode sobrecarregar o
rim.
Pessoas que tm dessa rara chamada
finilcetonúria
tem que ter monitoramento rigoroso da
finilalanina, que é aminoácido que essas
pessoas não conseguem metabolizar
adequadamente.
E pessoas alérgicas a proteínas
específicas como leite, soja e glúten,
tem que identificar alternativas
seguras.
Mantendo a adequação nutricional.
Lembrando que gestantes e lactantes têm
demandas proteicas aumentadas.
Bem, tem algumas perguntas aqui. Como
essa mulher pode evitar a atrofia do
braço que ficou quatro dias com gesso?
Quatro dias só. Não vai na trofia, não.
É 4 meses ou quro dias?
Deve ser 4 meses, né? Quatro dias. Tô
achando muito pouco tempo. Evitar não
vai. Aí tem que depois de tirar o gesso,
fazer musculação e aumentar o consumo
proteico. Como eu tava comentando agora
a pouco.
O que faz um homem ter voz fina?
Geralmente é deficiência de
testosterona, tá?
Ou características
pessoais aí, né? Pode ser só uma
variação da normalidade.
Boa noite, Dra. Ana Paula.
Sim. Eh, é muito comum homens que t
baixa testosterona na faixa aí de da
adolescência
ficarem com voz fina ou pode ser uma
característica mesmo pessoal, tá? que
não tem nada a ver com testosterona,
não. Tivemos aí assuntos de diferença
entre consumo de proteína vegetal e
animal. Teve um estudo aí de 9 dias de
duração que foi bem rigoroso, que
mostrou que não faz tanta diferença você
comer proteína vegana ou proteína de
várias fontes, sonívoro, né, carne
incluído. Se você for vegano, tem que
comer 10 a 20% a mais de proteína por
conta da menos variabilidade aminoácido
que tem dessas fontes. Resumindo,
pode ser insensibilidade a testosterona
quando fala alto começa a espirrar.
Existem uns casos raros que o receptor
de testosterona não responde bem à
testosterona, tá? Existe sim essa
resistência do receptor de testosterona.
Fale sobre SHBG, hormônios. Essa HBG é a
proteína carreadora de hormônio sexual,
é produzido pelo fígado, tem quatro
isoformas,
algumas têm mais afinidade pela
testosterona e outras menos. Quando a
pessoa tem inflamação sistêmica e tem
resistência insulínica, o SHBG tende a
ter mais afinidade pela testosterona
e tem níveis mais baixos, apesar de ter
mais afinidade.
Pessoas que tm então níveis altos de
insulina
com alta taxa de resistência insulínica
ou pré-diabetes tende ter o SHBG baixo,
porém tende ter maior ligação dessa
testosterona ao SHBG. Isso pode gerar
também
uma deficiência de testosterona livre e
também pessoas mais obesas
tendem a converter mais a testosterona
em estradiol. e ter problemas aí de
aromatização elevada e ter também
problemas aí de feminização, né?
Distribuição de gordura corporal em
lugares que é mais comum em mulheres.
Bem, temos uma hora de live aí. Se não
tiver mais dúvidas ao vivo, eu vou est
encerrando, tá, pessoal? Porque eu ainda
tenho que ir paraa academia hoje.
Se você tiver uma pergunta mais
específica sobre isso, você
pode fazer, tá? Falei assim em termos
bem gerais aí.
Bem, pessoal, para quem não acompanhou
ao vivo, né, vocês podem estar avisando
também no grupo que, como sempre todos
os vídeos ficam gravados, né? Então, não
é necessário tá sempre vendo os vídeos
ao vivo.
E aí, semana que vem, eu falo sobre a
vacina russa.
e sobre
aquela
psicologia de Leopold Zond, tá bom? Que
foram as perguntas que vieram agora meio
tardias. Um abraço para vocês. Até a
semana que vem.